sì
[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo
super grand skip è partito da dio perché
la musica a casa troppo c'è fantastico e
ma chi se ne frega dei comandi giochiamo
è un indio al ragazzo in in viola che va
bè ragazzi che cazzo click to con clima
fantastico bene siamo oggi siamo
schiantati non so dove così impari a
guidare senza guardare il cellulare
[ __ ] ok io effettivamente pensavo
che si fosse schiantato con una macchina
e questo ragazzi si insegna a non
guardare il cellulare quando si sta
guidando un aereo perché vi capiterà di
guidare un aereo e state attenti a non
guardare il telefono comunque la cosa
non capito e come mai stavamo guidando
un aereo e come cazzo ho fatto a
sopravvivere a quella roba lì è
impossibile però nero si è sentito cosa
è successo sono progressi comunque
ragazzi cos'è c'è una se una cabina di
qua e di là che cazzo c'è qualche
andiamo dopo chi se ne fotte comunque
l'ambientazione veramente fantasma
buongiorno salve è questo hotel di lusso
chi l'ha tirato su senta amica una suite
è entrato cazzo era perfetto era una
porta finta che siano perché c'è la
radiazione tm2 o dove m2 ma [ __ ] è
stata ascoltando il re di fuori di gore
non si di equa siamo su m2o va bene non
siamo qui per ascoltare la radio
dobbiamo trovare qualcos'altro
perché se no non trovo il senso comune
quella [ __ ] si è permesso ho visto un
tizio non c'è nessuno ho chiesto questa
cosa sa cosa mi sembra mi è sembrata
parecchio strana cimica qualcuno per no
perché prima è spuntato un tizio che non
gli piaceva per niente devo io passo di
cuochi non è chiuso perfetto atatra ce
la faccia una chiave madonna che cazzo
ragazzi queste sono le chiavi giu carlo
armato ammazza c'è come faccio a infatti
c'è un'altra porta qui
perfetto allora devo trovare un'altra
chiave credo perfetto no kids ex è un
tele è un telefono ragazzi l'iphone 6 in
anteprima su the ground skipper cos'è
sta roba ragazzi trovo trova in giro che
non ho capito che cos'è di quello di
quello
[Applauso]
vabbè ragazzi olivicoltori l'episodio se
vi dove è piaciuto che ci vediamo così
guido bei ragazzi e va bene so ancora
dove devo riuscire a fine sta roba che
va bene quindi lo sta roba ragazzi lo
faccio solo per voi perché vi amo
e significa tanto e dopo dopo tutto sto
casino significa veramente tanto
credetemi lì ecco è quella e l'uscita
sia io c io ci credo io ci credo ma ma
ma subito ci credo anche ragazzi ignora
il fatto perché sono entrati in questa
casa che cazzo sta suonando il telefono
avevo detto di spegnere whatsapp
maledizione maledette applicazioni
dell'iphone 6 che rimangono accese anche
quando spegne il telefono ragazzi ma
porca [ __ ] pronto pronto pizza dove si
pizza quattro formaggi grazie no 44 44
for 4 cosa cioè una pepsi ma [ __ ]
ultima [ __ ] volta che horn in una
pizza da voi bastardi e che bello che
bello sto bagno mi pregusto un attimo
infarto devo per caso farlo ok non ce
l'ha nessuno
pensavo ci fosse qualcuno effettivamente
che bella mandino ragazzi che per caso
la cosa nel cesso estate mi state
nascondendo qualcosa c'è una chiave
firenze
6 miglior chef o io non gioco coi
pastelli così tanto c'è una volta una
volta ho scarabocchiato un banco non so
se cambia qualcosa usa la chiave per
uscire
ok spero di no l'importante ragazze di e
che dovete portare sempre la radio con
voi perché alla porta aperta sul sito
non ci posso credere ok effettivamente
si poteva uscire mi sono stupito di sta
cosa conca ragazzi adesso che abbiamo
fatto sta cosa direi di andare all'altra
via quella che non avevo pagato di
striscio primo vero questa che ci sono
tre cartelli pure madonna montana ci
andiamo andiamo nei luoghi del weekes
legge questo qui abbiamo di quando non
so che non ai dari che cosa ci sia ma
visto quello che è successo prima non è
che ci vado così tranquillo comunque a
bebè loeb e lunedì ragazzi un edificio
più bello dell'altro un giorno sto per
entrare a c'è nessuno che bello che
bello ragazzi mi piacciono troppo se
edifici sono proprio contento di essere
qui va a fuoco fuoco e brutto stronzo di
merda ti ho detto che non si fuma in
casa bastardo vai dover estintore fermo
che cazzo fai no vieni subito quel
brutto stronzo dove vai dove vai
bastardo devi devi togliere il fuoco
ragazzi soffiate tutti tutti e soffiare
perché sennò si spegne come che sta
soffiando solo io alla fine va bene un
importo comunque grazie per avermi
guardato soffrire mentre soffiavo
soltanto io siete molto partecipi
no no no
dove cazzo siamo siccome amo questo
[ __ ] gioco andrò a vedere anche che
cosa c'è nell'altra via perché mi piace
tantissimo e quando avrò visto che cosa
c'è qui dentro c'è un pozzo c'è un po 70
ma come cazzo sei finito lì dentro la
pizza tela ordini da solo ragazzi mi
dispiace però non è che posso aiutare
tutti quanti qua c'è sto seguendo la
strada per qualcosa non ho capito cos'è
comunque tornerò ad aiutare il mio
amichetto è molto gentile
non so se sono io che ho sentito male ma
mi pare di aver sentito qualcosa non
bello diciamo calmo ei che cazzo è due
c'era un tizio c'era un [ __ ] tizio
ragazzi non mi ricordo più dove stavo
guardando però di aver azzeccato perché
russo a perfetto che curno perché non mi
dicono veramente più dove stava andando
dunque passa gente a caso nelle foreste
senza motivo cos'è sta roba un cancello
devo andare via domanda qui dietro
perfetto su una strada ragazzi ancora
non ho capito perchè certa gente che
gira a caso che dà fuoco alle cose che
si muove negli alberi e io prima mi lavo
di qui e prima cos'è sta roba
ma si sa ma è certo che non lo sapevo
c'era anche scritto il grosso come una
casa metti la chiave qui per aprire la
porta
perdonatemi ragazzi sono evidentemente
stupido comunque sia anche bel posto le
mie mi gianni gianni mi sono innamorato
di del disco posto è fantastico si
conosce molto spazio viva di una partita
a calcio non lo sto facciamo un undici
contro undici evidente perché ci sono
scosse cos'è sto schifo a terra
ehi guardate dove mette i piedi è che
poi pulite voi ragazzi che sta
succedendo qualcosa di parecchio strano
che ancora non misto non mi so spiegare
comunque prova a vedere queste parti non
si apre ovviamente si aprirà l'ultima in
fondo ma la smettete di far casino
no perché io sono qui sono ospite sono
sono ospite si trattano così gli ospiti
lui è cambiato mi dissero la stessa cosa
quando provate a truccarmi comunque
ragazzi non importa il che ha chiuso la
porta qui prima o poi troverà ragazzino
lo vedi quel coso che sta di fianco alla
porta
si chiama campanello tullo premi e non
bossi come un idiota che ai ragazzi il
mio destino e quello di girare a mozzo
presto castello per il resto della mia
vita mi dispiace c'è un coso nel
perfetto devo trovare qualche chiave di
sicuro quindi ragazzi qualcosa devo
trovare per forza anche se non ho capito
dove ci sarà qualche altra porta aperta
non è perfetto quella di forza ma ci
sono due porte aperte pino vista
soltanto una pressa chiuso ovviamente la
ci sarà questa preparatevi regate perché
di sicuro ci saranno non ci sara d'ora
l'esploratrice qui dietro però ma forse
c'è già stata
ragazzi credo poi capacità
macché camminata da minchione aveva
[Musica]
ragazzi sta causando capita ma non
importa andiamo avanti così trovare una
chiesa ma chi è quel monache che sbatte
la porta ragazzino non ho ancora capito
chi è che chiuse che chiude le porte in
sti post ma non fa niente andiamo avanti
così sia frequenta non si apre questa
dove tornare su vaffan
in totale se non sbaglio mi rimangono da
aprile tre porte quindi ragazzi dovremmo
essere anche questa finta di quella
[ __ ] prima i tavoli poi lei che cosa mi
volete tirare addosso un armadio così ci
siamo ne mancano due ok un giorno salve
e lei una bella donna è una bella donna
ma io vado via
grazie mille ragazzi la gente ospitale
come un dito nel ca pranzi mentale se ha
voglia di parlare di discutere
tranquillamente io io prendo questa cosa
qui che c'è a terra ok se non le
dispiace grazie io vado è finalmente
maledizione alla coscia
no questa non si apriva prima ok
perfetto questa è l'ultima porta ragazzi
poi ho finito di aprirle ho trovato la
chiave
devo andare a infilarla nel muro devo
andare a ciò i ragazzi mi sembra
incredibile non ci posso credere a primi
il mondo maledetta chiave è una chiave
un casino
cosa sta aprendo
ragazzi vi presento le tenute di san
crispino è bello bellissimo complimenti
io esco di qui se non mi dispiace se
siamo noi siamo nel sottosuolo di un
castello ripi lante abbandonato nel
bosco fantastico noi vive qua sotto opa
andate via
beh perfetto ascolterò il tuo consiglio
ragazzi qualcosa mi dice che dobbiamo
levarci dai [ __ ]
ma non possiamo farlo perché le porte
sono bloccate fantastico che voleva
andare a vedere il film di per papig al
cinema stasera era meglio quello
maledizione o forse no però di più o
meno san crispino a volontà
direi che è che qui c'è qualcuno che si
dà da fare vero c'è una c'è un altro
iphone che suona
quella [ __ ] che mi ami spunto ancora
qualcuno la devi smettere
hai rotto le palle hai rotto le fottute
palle devi capirlo che non puoi spuntare
in faccia la gente così ok ci siamo
capiti pronto
la pizza non la voglio che basta 31 una
pessima vergognati vergognati che hanno
anche la faccia tosta di attaccare ma
[ __ ] tanto cesta porta che sia
aperta che più oscura delle altre
maledizione e ancora non ho capito
ok ok ok ok ok ok c'è qualcuno che cazzo
c'è un tizio che crollano i corridoi
bellissimo si vede tutto ragazzi non
vedo un cazzo standards ragazzi dove
devo andare
madonna strumentazione mi sta bene
facendo venire un infarto vi giuro mi
son presto mi son perso aiuto
dei ragazzi cè un brutto gioco c'è chi
si trova la strada zitto che parlo io
sono più spaventato di tecco joanna che
almeno a me lo vedo dove sto andando
almeno quello altro è il tizio del pozzo
c'è una chiave nella stanza dietro di me
quale stanza ho lasciato una arrivo
arrivo ragazzi ti arrangi da solo
ragazzi aiuto ha visto a volte [ __ ]
di legno ai ragazzi ragazzi e ragazzi e
ragazzi e ma qualcuno l'ha di avvicinare
più tardi avvicinare
già
texture prime
sì è vero almeno niente forti alla fine
è già un traguardo ragazze e la casa che
vi vorrei far notare e come ci si fissa
addosso in questi video game novabell
scherzavo e te che mi si è rovesciata da
un altro uno spavento
io direi che per oggi comunque possiamo
concludere qui sto facendo attenzione
prima di tuffarmi ai video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato un commento mi
piace anche al paese di facebook e come
non i video trovate nella descrizione
scelse delfini si iscrive tecnici
diventiamo un prossimo video per ragazzi